نعم سيتتاثر راسنا المحتوى ايجابيا لكن
واثقا للقاعده العامه هناك رابح نعم لكن
هناك ايضا خاسر وفي معادله تويتر نادي
الخاسرين كان اكثر من الرابحين والصحفيون
قد يخسرون اذا انهارتر نحن هو من منصه
الساعه 60 يمكننا الجزماء بان عمل الصحفي
بات مرتبطا في جزء كبير بوجود هذه المساحه
ربما ساعدت سياسه التغريدات المختصره
سابقا باستقطاب في هذا العالم التقنيه
البسيطه ايضا كان لها دور كبير انت كصحفي
تتابع جهات من خبراء او سياسيين يوفرون لك
المعلومات
بنسختها الرقميه والوصف لانطوانه المسؤول
عن تحرير في معهد المعهد الوطني الفرنسي
للمواد السماعيه والمصريه بل تطور الامر
لان تصبح المنصه
ومصدرا للسبق الصحفي قبل ان يتدهور الوضع
كثيرا وتصبح المنصه حلبه مصارعه بين
الانتماءات المختلفه تويتر يدمر الصحافه
الامريكيه هكذا يرى مثلا الكاتب في صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز مانجو وذلك مع الوصول عدد
المستخدمين ل 2007 237 مليون مزاد من
هامشي نشر الاخبار المظلله امر اخر يؤثر
ايضا على الصحافه ما يجعل النعمه تتحول
لكن الكابوس الاسود ان يفشل الملك الجديد
الذي لا يخفى كره للصحفيين في انقاذ
الشركه لربما حان الوقت كما يقول احد
الصحفيين ان يعود الصحفيون الى طرق اعملهم
التقليديه في البحر